let's talk about the lefties because
i've got to calm down and i love those
people so look there there's a couple
decent liberals left there's there's not
really many of them and most of you know
my story and i generally like decent
liberals not woke progressive maniacs
but the few decent liberals that remain
i come from a family of what i would say
are old school jfk liberals for the most
part these people exist but many of them
i would say at this point have woken up
and have said you know what i don't
agree with everything on the
conservative side of things i think
abortion is one that a lot of them are
really concerned about most of them have
moderate beliefs on
uh on when you can do an abortion say 12
weeks something like that that's what i
lay out in my book and i know
conservatives don't agree with that yet
i still get invited to conservative
events and they don't throw eggs at me
while wearing gorilla masks
so i think most decent liberals at this
point have seen what time it is and are
leaving and the progressives can have
their increasingly
small group of hysterical lunatics that
just have a lot of power because they
scream and they control the institutions
well then there's guys like bill maher
bill maher who i've admired for 30 years
probably really since i was probably
like 12 or something and i started
watching politically and correct and i
was getting into stand-up comedy and
he's been the champion of of liberalism
right and even right now he fights
against woke-ism he fights for free
speech so he's right on a lot of these
things but he is struggling to figure
out what time it is and he sort of
addressed that on the show so let's play
the video and then i will analyze the
chat
to me when people say to me sometimes
like boy you know you go after the left
a lot these days why i'm like because
you're embarrassing me
that's why i'm going after the left in a
way you never did before because you're
inverting things that i i'm not going to
give up on being liberal this is what
these teachers are talking about that
you're taking children and making them
hyper aware of race in a way they
wouldn't otherwise be i mean i i saw
last night on the football game
uh alicia keys saying lift every voice
and sing
which now i hear is called the black
national anthem now maybe we should get
rid of our national anthem but i think
we should have one national anthem i
think when you go down a road where
you're having two different national
anthems
colleges sometimes now have many of them
have different graduation ceremonies for
black and white
separate dorms this is what i mean
segregation
you've inverted the idea
we're going back to that
under a different name
bill
you have to understand what's going on
here first off i just want to
say thank you for repeating everything
that i was saying five years ago right
i've been screaming about this stuff for
five years watch my why i left the left
video from prageru from five years ago
okay so that's nice and i know that your
guys watch my show so i'll talk directly
to the producers of the show everything
that bill said there is now conservative
yes we shouldn't have two national
anthems i don't know what he meant by we
should maybe change our national anthem
no we shouldn't um but yes they're
teaching racism in school they're
teaching this hyper-racialized thing in
school it's coming there's no liberals
to stand up for this stuff and then he
brings on people like adam schiff on his
show and it's obvious that he supports a
guy like adam schiff and we see this
with all the liberals a guy like bill uh
like joe rogan for example and these are
i'm really trying not to make these
personal attacks i'm trying to talk
about this in the idea set of what these
guys talk about joe rogan uh in in an
odd sense
did the right thing because he was a
bernie supporter which made no sense
right makes no in my view it makes no
sense to be a bernie supporter you sit
down with people like jordan peters and
all these brilliant people for years and
years and years and at the end when it
came down to it for the presidency you
were supporting uh you were supporting
bernie sanders makes no sense but joe
rogan when he signed the 100 million
dollar deal which i'm told is a lot more
than 100 million dollars with spotify he
lived in california and you know what he
did right before he signed the deal he
left he went to texas but the thing that
he was telling everybody to vote for
that he's voting for bernie sanders was
to raise taxes on everybody especially
people like him so the liberals in the
sense they're all still confused they're
looking at their watch and a watch
should be right twice a day but they
can't seem to ever get it right they
can't seem to ever get it right so it's
like bill maher
take the last step here i get it you're
in hollywood you've you've made your
career on being a liberal that is that
is a lofty goal and a worthwhile thing
trust me i get it more than most people
but at this point unless you're willing
to say i will not support any democrats
it doesn't mean the republicans are
great but everything you believe in is
now a republican principle now if you
really still think that high taxation
makes sense if you really still think
that handouts make sense and an
affirmative action makes sense and some
of that stuff well then we just got to
keep teaching you a little bit but i
don't even think he believes in that
stuff i've seen him talk to ben shapiro
he doesn't really disagree we could send
him a couple thomas soul videos i don't
think he disagrees with that but i get
it his whole brand and again this isn't
an attack on him his brand is i've been
the liberal like conservatives and this
is also the dangerous if you keep saying
that everybody else the conservatives
they're always racists and bigots and
backwards and in bill's case they're
also believers right they're believers
they're religious so they must be idiots
which is also a big problem that the
liberals have and they better freaking
get over it um well now like he's
painted himself in a corner so he can't
really do anything so anyway to the
producers that i know watch this which
is why bill repeats everything that i
say all the time because even the stuff
right there about national athens all
that like yeah doing it months ago it's
like bill's welcome here we'll do it
unedited i'm happy to be on his show i'm
not attacking him i don't even really
want to be on the show anymore i've been
canceled a couple times i'm sort of like
it doesn't even it's not even about me i
don't actually i sort of retract that it
doesn't even matter um but these last
liberals it doesn't make sense i saw
even that sam harris uh while i was gone
off the grid that he basically tweeted
out something to the effect of he's he's
swallowing his words related to
supporting biden it's like yeah we all
knew this was gonna happen but you guys
were so afraid of being called scary
conservatives so you'd rather vote to
destroy everything that america is but
show me a democrat willing to stand up
against this stuff so you can't support
adam schiff you can't tell people to
vote vote for bernie sanders you can't
sit there as the world burns and your
your entire side has collapsed i go ah
you're making liberals look bad it's
like no liberals made liberals look bad
right like like come on bill come on
bill